whales are majestic but very difficult
to study creatures taking off
three-two-one but drones are starting to
make whale research easier if a bit
Messier this is snot bot yes snot as in
whales not so what's so cool about whale
snot is they're blowing out not only the
actual sort of whale tissue at a very
small level but where we're getting
whale cells that will have DNA we're
getting the microbiome and we're also
getting hormones you know the hormones
that can tell us is the animal pregnant
is it lactating is it sexually active is
it is it stressed that's Ian curve
director of Ocean Alliance which
development I spoke with him about how
drones are transforming whale research
before the drone came along how did you
do a biopsy on an animal the size of a
school bus
so in our case we'd have quite a large
boat which was expensive and we actually
had a little boom that went out and I
would sit on the end of this boom
with a crossbow okay and we try to get
close enough to the whale to then biopsy
it where we shoot this crossbow and the
piece of tissue we get would be about
the end of your pinky finger or maybe
the size of an eraser on on a on a
pencil and that little piece of tissue
would have all of this biological data
but what's interesting here is that that
biological data was more often than not
legacy data you know this is what had
happened
so we're almost interested in what's
going on right now so when you get an
exhalation that's really speaking to the
condition of the animal right then and
there which is pretty exciting certainly
the exhaled breath condensate or whale
snot we're not at that point right now
where we're getting all of the data that
we're getting from the biopsy sample but
the very fact that it's non-invasive is
important and also it's more
cost-effective
you know it's we can run a drone from a
small boat
when I was sitting on the bow of a boat
with my my biopsy crossbow I almost felt
like I was playing whack-a-mole because
a whale would appear over there and I
I'd race over there and then oh it would
die but the way it would appear over
there and then I'd race over there and
then it would dive and you know I almost
felt like I was sitting on the bow of
the boat ripping up hundred-dollar bills
because it was costing a lot of money
and I wasn't collecting the data and I'm
like God if only I could just like fly
over there and grab that data and in
fact it was of one of these very
frustrating days we were down in the
Gulf of Mexico are working with sperm
whales after the Deepwater Horizon
disaster and the whale had dived and it
was the end of the day and my god I
hadn't got any samples and this cloud of
snot engulfed me and it was wonderfully
horrible you know was sticky and smelly
and all of those things that technically
a biologic biologist is meant to like
I'm not sure how much I was liking it at
the time but that's when I realized why
maybe maybe maybe I smell an idea here I
smell a solution I got asked for you to
elaborate there what does it smell like
in a cloud of wealth not well you know
guess what it's almost what you think
and it's somewhat dependent on what the
animals are eating do you not I mean
like blue whales that are eating krill
are not as bad as humpback whales that
are eating sand eels but you know
they're this a volume issue here you
know I mean a blue whale's lungs are
about the size of a VW so imagine
they're exhaling this I mean you are
immersed in this cloud of you know of
the worst bad breath you you've ever
smelled the things you do for science I
guess huh that's right that's right and
the things we're excited about I mean
who would have thought can you walk us
through the development of the snot bot
some maybe some design challenges that
you came across in the beginning and and
how you surmounted those when I started
with this it was a little bit
counterintuitive because if you think
about it the whale is blowing up and the
drone is blowing
down so the early prototypes we actually
had poles sticking down you know the
drum was here on the pole was down it's
like two feet long at the bottom of the
pole I had sponges and wedding veil and
meshes and what I realized quite quickly
some of these things that were great at
absorbing the blow you then had to get
them out again and suddenly now how do I
know that that wedding veil isn't
leeching you know plastic sort of
toxicant you know what I mean
that that would actually affect my data
but we notice when we're flying into the
blow we've been getting snot on the top
of the drone and I think what was going
on is that the drone sucking all this
air in so if we sort of came up behind
the whale the snot was already on that
trajectory but it was sucking it back
onto our drone so incredibly
counterintuitive we just started putting
petri dishes on the top of the drone you
collect the snot you get back on land
what do you then do to analyze that
sample and what exactly are you looking
for and the drone comes in and we just
close a petri dish we take it back to
our hotel that night and there's a
wonderful sound of one of the team with
a mask on they literally have like a car
a mini car squeegee and they go like and
they suck a snot into a little cryo
valve that we then send to different
laboratories you're also able to
identify the whales by the shape of
their flukes
can you talk about how that technology
works when you're looking at these
animals it's long been an issue of how
can we identify them and what's cool is
a lot of whales lift their tails up and
basically the patterns on the back of
their flutes are very unique and they
tend to stay with the animal from birth
now the flukes can actually get bite
scars and scratches on them but
generally lots of whale flukes have been
a very useful way to track an animal
throughout its life which is very
exciting I
you think with drones so we'll be using
more looking down maybe patterns on
their back maybe they're sort of
pectoral fins and maybe even their
blowhole so I think that's going to
change but the fact that when when we
fly our drones like to collect snot
we're recording from the time we leave
the boat till the time we get back
is there any artificial intelligence
involved there in identifying the Fluke
are you doing that all still by sight
we're doing it by sight we actually
worked on a project with Intel they came
onboard and used some pretty high
computing powers to help us and we were
flying out over a whale and they
actually took the live feed and
interrogated this database of while I
was still flying so within a 20-minute
window they said Ian you last saw that
whale 10 years ago 20 miles from here
so imagine if we knew that animal had
been sick or that animal had been hit by
a ship or that animal had been caught in
a net you know or the animal had a calf
knowing what animal we were working with
on knowing the life history of the whale
while we're with that animal would
certainly make the work more affordable
we'd sort of get a larger dataset people
like me have lived in a world a sort of
data deficit you know when you're
studying a rhino it doesn't dive beneath
the Serengeti after throwing a bucket of
water on you and a pier five miles away
you can sort of stay with that Rhino
whales are really difficult animals to
study you know they disappear under the
water and maybe spend more of that time
underwater doing the things that really
make up their lives and that's why it's
so exciting that we can look at these
hormone hormonal clues when the animals
exhale as to what's been going on over
the last hour and are there any
indications that the animals are at all
bothered by a snap but obviously it's
not as invasive as the previous method
but do they panic at all when you fly
over them yeah you know I think that's a
really good question and actually you
need to put me to work we have a
publication that I'm hoping
we'll be out within the next month and
basically in 370 flights we had 14
reactions to get the permit for the work
actually there was great concern about
sort of acoustic disturbance but what's
actually interesting and we wrote a
paper on this and a couple of other
people have written a paper on it the
high frequency sound doesn't get through
the water so a low frequency sound like
a helicopter an airplane you know is
like what whop whop whop whop does get
through the water but the high frequency
sound that might be incredibly
irritating to a set sort of way doesn't
seem to get through the water generally
speaking I think really good question
but data to date suggests it's very
minimally invasive so what comes next
here with your projects will stop up I'm
still trying to push what other
technologies can we use we used a
thermal camera to see if we could
measure the body temperature of a whale
by looking down the blowhole so we're
really excited to see if we can measure
body temperature and also then if the
body temperature is elevated we'd say
okay what else can we do with the drone
or should we dig deeper on this hormone
work I'm also very interested in in
potentially fleets of drones can we take
almost a three-dimensional picture of a
whale with multiple drones can we do
sort of morphometrics look at body
condition to help estimate the health of
a whale and you know ultimately there
might even be intubation programs where
a whale has been had a scar it's been
cut it's being infected maybe a drum
will come along and shoot antibiotics
into the whale to help it deal with its
infection using other drones we have one
drone we affectionately call ear BOTS
where we drop the drone in the water
with a Hydra phone and record the
vocalizations now what will be exciting
is if we can land multiple drones in the
water we might actually be able to say
wait a minute this animals talking to
that animal and this animals
plying better understanding how they
communicate with each other you know
could could provide some just amazing
insights into their lives thank you very
much
[Music]